all right we are going to get into
hatred mail quick reminder about what
hatred mail is because we cling to our
guns and our God but somehow totally
cool with a billionaire who wants to
assault our wife Patriot man written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom all right
let's get right into it I don't want to
delay any further because the key piece
of hatred mail is hatred mail let's
listen loser ha ha ha
Trump wins again never trust a liberal
Jew Pakman you are so brain dead and
please don't talk about circumcision or
if you do call it by its proper name of
male genital mutilation you took it from
Rachel Maddox yes Rachel Maddox who is
not a journalist I'm familiar with I I
know Rachel Maddow but I don't know who
Rachel Maddox is Rachel Maddox is who I
stole a story about male genital
mutilation which is now the way I'm
going to refer to whatever it is this
person is talking about yeah with that
word mute Italian and also using Rachel
Maddow spelled with an X I wonder if
he's just using the French spelling in
these words yes Oh clearly well I mean
if if what you're suggesting is it's not
clear English as this hatreds first
language I know why you think that but
you would be surprised at the type of
stuff that that we receive but I can
assure you I've stolen nothing from
Rachel Maddox turn hatred mail into
something positive
you can use the coupon code Maddox
that's that's just you know you can't
beat that coupon code Patriot 40 at
david pakman.com slash membership huge
membership discount if you use coupon
code hey tree at 40